the most profound Technologies are those
that disappear they weave themselves
into the fabric of everyday life until
they are indistinguishable from it
why do you think that Blackhawk
helicopters intimidate the people who
are at the Skinwalker Ranch seemingly
intentionally
okay so Skinwalker is going to be tough
for me uh simply because I worked in
television a lot and I am not going to
say any of those scenes were fabricated
but what I can say from exp and you're
you're referring to just to make sure
I'm clear prior to answering you're
referring to what's been coming out on
the show right also Brandon's personal
testimonial and I'm unsure if all of
what he's saying has been documented on
the television show and when I say
Brandon me Brandon fugle for people who
are one yeah
yeah so then I'll make it quick with the
television reference because I think a
lot of people do base the the Blackhawks
coming in from the television series and
to be honest with you I have no idea
if if it's actually happening the way
that the television show is conveying it
and I speak from experience with that
just because I saw it so many times and
I hated it it's one of the reasons why I
don't work in non-fiction programming
and anymore uh simply because there was
a lot of fictionalized elements to
non-fiction that I just hated so when I
see television shows like Skinwalker
Ranch and this is not against Brandon or
the production staff I know both uh
sides of of their production
um it's not against them but I don't
know if things are embellished I don't
know if it's exactly true based on
testimony itself I mean look you've got
a lot of military installations truly
everywhere uh but in places like Utah
stuff like that you're gonna have
flights
um I've had military helicopters come
over my area here in a city called
Castaic it's in Northern Los Angeles
there's actually not really a military
base that close here but they're they're
you know they're they're around I mean
maybe within 45 minutes driving or so so
so that they're close enough but I've
had it I don't read into it they have
flight paths just like everyone else
especially in those areas like Utah
that's going to have quite a few
military installations so are they
buzzing Skinwalker I mean I'd like to
see a little bit more proof of that why
would they be doing it and of course
again everything has a paper trail you
can't just throw a Blackhawk helicopter
over a private Ranch in Utah and have it
circled for no reason
but on top of that you can't do it
without a paper trail of some kind
you're going to have air traffic control
logs you're going to have where did it
come from you're going to have all that
so I'm happy to help anybody who has
those types of stories Brandon included
who I actually like a lot is it seems
like a really nice gentleman I've spoken
to him quite a few times
um I don't that doesn't mean that
everything is come out of coming out of
skinwalker's gospel but I really like
Brandon but people like Brandon that
have those types of stories hey I'm
happy to help them and and get those
logs and figure out where this
information can be found and and help
support those types of stories and I've
done that with past UFO cases I've got
Air Traffic Control recordings from UFO
stories
um I grabbed one from even the social
media Reddit and I was like ah well
let's see what I can find and sure
enough found the actual recording
um based on that somebody started
feeding me UFO cases that were
essentially being bantered about by by
the FAA started going after those two
and getting some really cool results so
my whole point is is that when people
have stories they shouldn't be
discounted but it's harder to base an
opinion just on the story let's go for
evidence you know and and that's how I
try and approach it especially with
those FAA cases the story Standalone
wasn't impressive at FAA traffic audio
to it that became a lot cooler and
that's that's what I mean by that and so
yeah Blackhawk helicopters are buzzing
Skinwalker or anywhere for that matter
let me know I'm happy to help let's
imagine Brandon fugle's watching this
right now your message is hey contact me
I will help you figure out what's going
on with regard to the Blackhawks yeah
yeah absolutely yeah and
full stop I mean I have no no problem I
have no again I'll use the Expression no
skin in the game either way to prove or
disprove if if somebody says a Blackhawk
was there cool it came from somewhere so
let's figure that out and uh go for
Tower logs prove that the flight was
there there's a lot of public uh sourced
information too that could potentially
show flight path and stuff like that so
if he says it's circling I'm sure we
could prove that too and he's a pilot so
he knows that better better than I do
John what do you want to be remembered
for
I know I don't even know if I'll be
remembered I like I don't even really
think about that
um
that's a tough one uh when it when it
comes to my public life uh look I want
to be remembered as as someone who cared
about bringing the truth forward
whatever that is you know uh it
it it
can go any which direction but I want to
be known as that guy that really tried
to to inform the masses uh of what that
truth is
more than that a good dad and husband
but uh you know attributing it to what
our conversation is uh going after the
truth and and and uncovering every piece
of the puzzle that can be uncovered and
giving the pieces to everyone else you
just watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy